hey guys you see here with a quick
gamespot news update for you Sony's
games division have posted a staggering
404 million dollar operating profit in
the 12 months following april 2014 which
is kind of a lot the upbeat financial
results were in part due to strong
playstation 4 sales which reached 14.8
million units worldwide junior 12-month
period sony expects these numbers will
accelerate upwards predicting 16 million
more ps4 units sold in the 12 months
from april 2015 however it's possible
division which includes the PlayStation
Vita and PlayStation TV yes remember
PlayStation TV continue to slide sales
fell to 3.3 million for the financial
year down from 4.1 million a year prior
unsurprisingly playstation 3 hardware
and software sales also continued to
decline sony noted that the strong
overall performance rich playstation
division was also due to a significant
increase in network revenue as well as
robust game software sales income
testing all its business performances
from photography to phones the wider
Sony Corporation announced a 576 million
dollar profit a figure up 159 percent
year-on-year this year's earnings mark
Sony's biggest annual operating profit
in the past seven years which has been a
dour period for the company in which it
had to revise its income projections
downwards on 15 separate occasions more
promising news for investors came from
Sony's financial year projections with
the company expecting its profits to
quadruple over the next 12 months so yes
well done Sony are you impressed by
their financials do you own a
PlayStation TV have you ever met anyone
who owns a PlayStation TV let me know in
the comments section below and for your
latest gaming news make sure to keep it
gamespot
caught on tape it below or sentence it's
a great sense Rob so yes well done sony